it's been a busy day for the American
president after a tense call with the
Chinese leader it was to the podium in
the White House to tell the American
people don't panic about the economy let
me just give you what the facts are in
terms of the state of the economy number
one we have a record job market
of record unemployment of 3.6 percent
today
we've created nine million new jobs so
far just since we become president that
doesn't sound like a recession to me
thank you very much
he's not wrong unemployment is at record
lows and with the midterms upcoming his
message needs to be or will be well but
on the nation's growth take a look at
the difference a year makes with war
covid and inflation
6.3 percent growth for the first three
months of last year more in the second
quarter a covert dip and then more steel
as the economy bounced back from the
pandemic
but then the headwinds the economic and
supply chain impact of the war in
Ukraine inflation and measures to
correct rocketing costs there was some
hope that it would grow just a little in
the past three months but instead it
shrank by 0.9 percent
the second key point I'd say Mr
President is there balances are much
higher than they were in a pandemic with
the chief Executives of some of
America's top companies the message was
that his path is the right one but the
global challenges are unprecedented time
again to test that old cliche when
America sneezes the world catches a cold
what I'm really
worried about and I suspect the rest of
the world is really worried about is if
the real economy slows in the U.S but
inflation remains high that is the worst
of Both Worlds and it suggests that we
have darker days ahead and that's when
the world does catch a cold yes I mean
that is when the U.S is you know
shivering under the covers with a fever
and the rest of the world is worried
about catching that disease absolutely
recession or not the economic balances
right now are delicate and dependent on
so much and at a time when things feel
particularly unpredictable Mark Stone
Sky News in Washington